So, this happened
[Classical music plays]
Well yeah, but no like show- show earlier
Past Anna: [Sigh] I'm so horny
No after that nobody needs to see that Past Anna: Yo you want to fuck, homie?
I mean in so many words, but that wasn't exactly how -- who the fuck is running these cutaways?
Yeah
So basically I texted a co-worker that I know and asked him if you want to come over and have meaningless sex one time
So we did and of course the next morning.
Matthew: It was great to see you.
Anna: Yeah, thanks so much for having me or coming over, uh, the sex you get it. You get it.
Matthew: Well, you're welcome. I'll see you soon.
Anna: See you soon. Bye.
Anna:Now that I've obtained his dick
I must obtain his heart because of course I
Can't just have a one-night stand without my emotions and heart and head getting all confused
no, that would just make life way too easy, right? So I did what I do best
I was mega extra. Hey, want to hang? What are you doing? What are your thoughts about aliens? I felt like a total idiot
I mean here I was telling this guy I could be casual and do this thing one time
And it would be all fine, and then just immediately turning around and giving him the exact opposite signal
I think the good news is even when you're a hypocrite as long as you're communicative, you're probably okay
Matthew: I'm confused.
Anna: I totally understand. I'm so sorry
Anna: It's just I'm used to being in a relationship and heavily relying on an emotional connection
Anna: ...and you're such a great person that when we got physically intimate I got really confused and thought you're the person I'm supposed to be with
Anna: Now but I got all my feelings orders that we're good to go
Matthew:Wow, okay, that makes sense. I mean I am the first person you hooked up with since your breakup, right? Yeah, that's totally normal
Matthew:We're good. You're fine now
Matthew: I'm glad we had this talk.
Anna: Thank you so much for understanding, and I'm really sorry again. Do you want to stay and have dinner?
Matthew: No
Anna: Okay, sorry old habits die hard
Matthew: Yeah, don't worry about it.
Anna:I really wanna get married and have kids at some point. So you know looking for a meaningful relationship
Matthew: Right, yeah.
Anna:Yeah want to lock it down
Anna: Really want to get that half a baby!
Matthew:Half a baby?
Anna: Baby, it's like a half-white, half-Asian, baby. They're really beautiful.
Matthew: Like half Asian, half British, or...?
Anna: It could be! If you're down
Matthew: Yeah, I mean, I'll think about it.
Anna: Okay.
Matthew: Should I?
Anna: Yeah, sure.
Matthew:I'll catch you soon.
Anna:Okay, bye! Live and learn.
Now I know that
I am not built to have one-night stands because I crave
Emotional connection more than I do physical ones and trying to be sexually intimate with a caveat of it being casual is beyond the scope
Of my maturity levels so I guess my advice to you is to figure out what you want and be very upfront about it even
If you quickly realize-oh, no, I was wrong. I am not built for this- just own up to it.
It'll be fine. I'm Anna Akana, see you soon.
Anna:Thank you so much to Matthew for being in today's episode. You can actually click on his adorable face to follow this channel on
Dating and relationships. I watched a bunch of his videos, and they're all really amazing.
Matthew: Thank you.
Anna: Yeah, thank you
Matthew:Feeling's mutual
Anna: Oh yay, thanks, and thank you for all the great advice on dating because it's totally applicable to my life right now
Matthew: I hope it helps everybody
Anna: Yeah. Don't forget to follow his channel and check out all his great stuff. Thanks for watching, bye!